San Francisco just hosted Ron DeSantis
or rather Ron DeSantis chose to go to
San Francisco as he makes his campaign
for presidency not just about a handful
of States but about coast to coast and a
major cultural change here's what the
governor said
you look around uh the city is not
vibrant anymore it's really collapsed
because of leftist policies and these
policies have caused people to flee this
area they don't prosecute criminals like
they do in most parts of the country and
the wreckage has really really been sad
to see and so I've seen so many
businesses boarded up I've seen so much
uh riffraff just running around and it
just shows you these policies matter
leadership matters they are doing it
wrong here
I really like this look
I like this look of Ron DeSantis being
out in The Fray in front of this
graffitied up building all this trash on
the street in California what's he doing
in California I like that
I wish we saw more of the delivery here
I wish we saw more of the interaction
uh what I've heard about this trip is
that people are coming up to DeSantis in
California and saying hey man we support
you you know
regular good sort of ordinary American
people that we all like and support the
crazy Libs they all were yelling at
desantas but the normal nice people and
the First Responders and the cool guys
they all like DeSantis
so I'd like to see more of that I want
to see more interaction
want to see DeSantis out in the world
the knock on DeSantis right now
is that he's a little too stiff he's not
good enough with people he doesn't have
enough Riz you know to use my Zoomer
lingo
that he he's he's running
there's a little bit of a I don't know
focused group tested type of
establishment candidate and he shouldn't
run that way and he doesn't need to run
that way so put him out there yes send
him to San Francisco and let's see him
in that Fray that's something that that
Trump has that that uh DeSantis really
needs to to go after best I've seen him
but we should go even further down that
line if we're talking about a DeSantis
kind of campaign
and I got bad news for DeSantis which is
that Trump continues to dominate in the
polls and he's getting stronger and
stronger in the polls there's a poll
right now out of Quinnipiac that shows
Trump not only beating the rest of the
GOP field by a lot which he's doing but
Trump beating Biden and and not just
Trump beating Biden at the national
level which the other night we were on
Backstage and I was trying to explain to
my friend and colleague Ben Shapiro that
Trump is a lot stronger than than the
people who don't like Trump or letting
on and I said well one example is that
Trump is beating Biden in the polls he
says well those are just National polls
and National polls don't matter because
the elections come down to just a
handful of states and not even a whole
lot of counties well now we have a poll
out from Quinnipiac which shows Trump
beating Biden in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania is supposed to be Joe
Biden's home turf good old Scranton Joe
and Trump is beating him there head to
head
47-46 so it's close
but Trump is still ahead there so the
argument
that Trump can't win
is falling apart
they are it I always thought it was a
silly argument because he won in 2016.
so the people who say Trump will never
ever win is going to destroy the GOP
they were wrong in 2016. but yeah okay
he was not able to remain the president
after the 2020 election how's that for a
diplomatic way of putting it uh and and
he is off-putting to a lot of people and
he does need to do a better job of
appealing to people who are a little
more Centrist and a little bit more in
the middle I'm not denying any of that
it's just Biden looks so terrible right
now and Trump looks so unfairly
persecuted that even in a place like
Pennsylvania Trump is currently leading
so now one of the big anti-trump lines
in the primary is gone
it's gone on the idea that he came when
it's going on the idea that well the
national polls don't matter yeah maybe
the national polls don't tell you
everything but the state polls do and
even in the contentious Battleground
State polls Trump's looking pretty good
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
central banks in countries such as China
China India and Australia have announced
they are beginning to explore
transitioning to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with the digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
seize part or all of your money Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold you can do that with the help of
Birch gold they are the guys that I get
my gold from so do thousands of other
concerned Savers Birch gold will help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold you won't pay a penny out
of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of Abby
customers text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend on text Knowles to 98 98
98 so what is DeSantis going to say to
this well the DeSantis campaign pitch is
going to be
that Trump had the right idea but he
failed in the execution and I'm going to
be the better Trump most of us in this
room voted to drain the swamp twice I
talked to us specifically about why
you're the right candidate to folks in
New Hampshire to come behind in this
primary to drain the swamp and get it
done this time as opposed to the other
choice it's a great great question and
what's your name
okay thanks Mark so the question is and
I remember these rallies in 2016. it was
exciting drain the swamp I also remember
lock her up lock her up right and then
two weeks after the election oh don't
forget about it forget I ever said that
no no no one thing you'll get from me if
I tell you I'm going to do something I'm
not just saying that for an election and
there are promises I could make that may
help me marginally politically that I
don't know that I could that I could
necessarily follow through on so I will
not make that and I think the idea of
draining the swamp in some respects it I
think it misses it a little bit because
if you we didn't drain it it's worse
today than it's ever been by far uh and
that's a sad Testament to the state
affairs of our country but even if
you're successful at draining it the
next guy can just refill it so I want to
break the swamp that's really what we
need to do
that's a sophisticated point
which is that not only do you need to
fire the bad people but you need to
change the structure
that that is causing the problems in the
first place it's all good and it all
comes down to this idea that DeSantis is
Trump 2.0 better bigger faster stronger
more precise better at wielding politics
Trump's big strength was that he's a
political Outsider and and doesn't
really know how Washington Works
DeSantis does get how Washington Works
he was a congressman he's been an
effective Governor so he's going to take
trumpism and really put it into effect
that's the line
and it's not going to work that's not
going to be and if that is all the
campaign is about then the SanDisk
campaign's not going to win
because it's New Coke versus Coca-Cola
classic
Coca-Cola classic which is the Coca-Cola
that we all have today people really
like it and then
some 30 40 years ago was it that long at
this point yeah I guess it is
Coca-Cola decides they've got a new Coke
formula and they bring it out and it's a
complete disaster and they have to
return to the old Coke formula well why
did they bring it out was it just some
Rogue marketing executive who screwed
things up no they tested New Coke over
and over and over again and when people
were given blind taste tests of New Coke
versus the old Coke people preferred the
new Coke
but when the blindfold came off and they
knew
what the brands were and they they had a
choice between that old thing the OG and
the new and improved version
they picked the original
and that's exactly what's going on in
the GOP Primary right now you could say
that DeSantis is better at wielding
power and implementing these things and
he's more philosophically and
ideologically coherent and he
understands politics better and you
could go down the whole Litany of
compliments yeah that might be true but
the way that people respond to that the
way that psychology works is that
people like that original thing you know
and Trump is an American original so if
the the Santa's campaign is going to be
effective it's going to need something
in addition to I'm just the bigger
better Trump what a great clip that was
make sure that you subscribe you ring
that Bell you get every episode every
interview every yes or no game we'll see
you next time